[Music]
or celebrities going into a cheese
grinder or celebrities going into
solar-panel you decide no I don't know
it's a very strange graphic all right
please make that go away it's making you
sick here we go here's how the survey
works we asked three celebrities to
complete a phrase our first phrase was
if I weren't running for president I
would be Hillary Clinton said acting as
a political consultant Jeb Bush said
continuing with my charity work
promoting literacy Bernie Sanders said
screaming at a nurse to turn up the
volume on the tongue
[Applause]
my style can best be described as Lena
Dunham said New York nerd Jennifer
Aniston said Malibu casual Miley Cyrus
said mental hospital Arabic sister when
kids see me they always say Chris Pratt
said it's Peter from guardians of the
galaxy
Daniel Radcliffe said it's Harry Potter
Tommy Lee Jones said mommy why is that
tree matter
[Applause]
that'll teach you to pick apples well
[Laughter]
what could he do to me uh a lot of
voters wish that I was Bernie Sanders
said younger Chris Christie said thinner
Donald Trump said kidding
as a woman and a mother I Hillary
Clinton said understand the women in
this country Sarah Palin said no how to
connect with female voters Lindsey
Graham said dammit i'ma fella Lindsey
when I heard the Hyatt Hotel chains will
no longer offer adult movies on demand
I thought Kristen Bell said good it
wasn't Biff banks said now my kids and I
can stay there Andy Richter said well I
guess it's time to give internet porn a
trial opposites attract which is why my
wife is Howie Mandel said shy and
reserved Keith Urban said tall and
outgoing Vin Diesel said slow and
uncurious
I have a rather impressive collection of
Stephen King said antique sleds john c
reilly said old whiskey bottles Bill
Cosby said pending lawsuits I started
using bronzer Marissa Miller said for
photo shoots
Bradley Cooper said for publicity shots
Larry King said during the Bronze Age
and finally if elected president the
first foreign leader I'd meet with is
Mike Huckabee said Russia's Vladimir
Putin Marco Rubio said Germany's Angela
Merkel chris Christie said China's
General Tso
oh yeah what do you say you say I say
general orange chicken reporting for
duty hey thanks for watching be sure to
click subscribe to see even more great
Conan clips you may now return to your
pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography